were you good at these games growing up
did you have a favorite especially a
marble game yeah oh sure yeah
yeah one very special detail on set
could have helped the squid game players
survive from giant dolls to mind bending
stairs inspired by a piece of art the
team behind squid game went all out with
their sets
while cgi is used to create or complete
certain images many of the sets and
backdrops seen in squid game were
fabricated just for the show this is
extra impressive because some of the
real sets look like they could be
created by computers with just how
mesmerizing and exciting they look
especially when the backdrops appear to
be outdoor locations
tug of war might seem like a simple
enough game to film but the team behind
the netflix hit opted to build a large
space and the raised platforms used in
the game from scratch the space created
managed to be the perfect base for the
actors to perform on and to add cgi
effects afterwards to make the space
seem as daunting as it feels for the
actors every inch had to be precisely
built to ensure the safety of the
performers while doing such physical
work
the dorms the players stay in during
squid game may be the dullest colored
set but it's certainly not the least
impressive the gray walls and metal bunk
beds aren't so inviting or comforting
but they definitely set the scene and
make an impact the size of the space was
so vast that for the performers it could
feel like they were in a coliseum the
dorm space is where so much happens a
major fight learning the truth of the
game watching the money add up and the
prison-like aesthetic provided the ideal
backdrop for these pivotal moments
if you do not wish to participate
then please let us know at this time not
a single detail was overlooked when the
art department and creative team worked
to bring all the spaces we see in squid
game to the screen
one very small but meaningful detail one
that even could have helped the players
out a bit was hiding in plain sight on
the walls
we don't see them in the first part of
the series but as players lose and there
isn't a need for so many beds we slowly
see the images revealed all the
illustrations on the walls depict each
of the games played throughout the
series the fact that the bunk beds were
in tall stacks was no coincidence either
the art director thought them up to
convey themes of abandonment and
carrying emotional baggage
they were actually made out of the same
material as tunnels
the colorful and unsettling sets of
staircases we see in squid game were
actually inspired by a famous piece of
art called relativity the original image
came from the mind of a dutch artist
named mcesher
the squid game creative team felt the
mind-bending picture would be the
perfect addition to the series and they
weren't wrong
the original photo includes seven
stairways arranged in a world where
gravity is different and considering
squid game really turns every player's
life upside down whether they want it to
or not the homage paid to this classic
piece of art makes a lot of sense and
just adds to the genius of the show
whoa this place is gigantic
a part of what makes these sets so
incredible is the sheer scale of them
the space of the children's playground
for the honeycomb game featured real
enormous versions of playground
equipment with a fake drawn sky
background making the whole scene look
like an image we'd see in a children's
book it did an incredible job at
bringing us a freaky playground vibe the
large-scale equipment also helped with
making the players feel like children
replicating what the environment would
have looked like to them when they were
young the team definitely accomplished
the formidable but also familiar and
reminiscent of childhood look that
director huang was hoping to achieve
so our options are circle triangle
star umbrella
we can't discuss the incredible sets
without mentioning one very impactful
prop
if that's what we call a creepy giant
doll that had the power to take any
player out that it saw moving the red
light green light doll is a major part
of the scene for the initial game and
shockingly wasn't created just for the
show yes this terrifying giant mugunkwat
doll actually existed before and was
displayed for the public to see at a
museum adventure village in south korea
the doll is back in its original home
since the production wrap so people can
see this amazing piece of the squid game
story in person
it seems like the games were tough for
the doll as well since it now is
inexplicably missing one of its hands
some cast members were actually
speechless when they were on set for the
first time thrilled by the fact that
they'd get to interact and perform in
these incredible spaces the actor who
plays number one had a really intense
nostalgic reaction when he was on set
where the marbles game takes place
all the houses and streets we see were
built from the ground up no small feat
but so worth the final incredible
product the set had the power to
transport the cast members themselves to
other places so it's no surprise they've
completely captured us
for director of the series huang it was
important to build an authentic world so
the team could more easily tell the
story truthfully meaning not a lot of
cgi ended up being used
not a corner was cut and the squid game
team decided to really build everything
we see oftentimes extremely large
versions which only added to the
impressive production one of the coolest
examples of a non-cgi shot is the very
first game red light green light where
there were actually over 400 performers
on the set playing the game often times
in scenes like these loads of people end
up being added in with cgi but since the
set itself was so enormous they were
able to accommodate a massive cast and
crew
over there
looks really freaky for the performers
seeing the sets for the first time blew
them away and they needed to capture the
magic
the cast had of course had time with the
script for a while before they arrived
to film and when reading naturally
thought up of what the sets were going
to look like for the most part it was
not at all what they'd expected and some
actors were even caught off guard
shocked that these incredible spaces
existed and that they were the lucky
actors who got to perform on them for
other actors the set felt a bit like a
fantasy or dream world
the colors and childlike structures are
surprising and catch audiences off-guard
in a fantastic way as well the sheer
scale of it all was overwhelming but the
performers managed to fill the space
right up with their incredible acting
with so many interesting locations it's
a bit surprising that the whole
production is filmed in just one city
about an hour outside of seoul south
korea is daejeon this city has been the
home base for many south korean
productions and is now home to squid
game where so much magic was created
since there wasn't any big traveling
being done the budget for the set could
be a bit higher and the team took
advantage of it
these creations were far from cheap
[Music]
there was just as much action behind the
scenes as on screen with camera people
running around and intense visual
effects being produced live
the glass stone's ending definitely
caught us off guard but the process to
capture the way it surprised kyon
seibiak and sang wu was an extensive one
filming the actors only had a small
amount of glass explode near them the
slow motion feeling really comes through
in how the actors perform
after capturing shots of the trio each
got to do their close-up work with
singles as well
it may be a short moment but plenty of
hours were put into capturing every
nuance and angle
when time came for the big visual of the
glass stepping stones we see exploding
the team didn't resort to cgi for the
shards of glass
except for the ones that appeared to
harm the players and fly towards the
camera they actually went ahead and
created the whole sequence in studio
these practical effects look unreal on
the set it's no surprise it translates
to such a powerful and stunning visual
in the episode
hello players let me welcome you all to
the fifth game
the cast of squid game dove right in
when playing glass stepping stones and
definitely didn't have it easy since for
many it was actually terrifying to film
while cgi came into play in terms of
establishing the setting and just how
high in the air the players were much of
the carnival-like set was fully built
even the glass fortunately no one
actually went through shattering glass
instead landing on a board supported by
a crew to allow the actor to fall safely
[Music]
in the show the set that red light green
light takes place on already seems
awfully crowded with the nearly 500
players but on the set there were even
more folks making it a pretty chaotic
yet well-organized space we would have
thought cgi was used to add the bodies
of those who lost during the game
especially the piles of people at the
doors but the actors all actually stayed
wherever they were when they lost the
game which couldn't have been very
comfortable when it came to filming
close-ups multiple cameras were used to
capture the performances and the filming
crew was often running along with the
players
the added detail of using a red marker
to signal when a person took a shot is
evident of just how thorough and
meticulous the team was no one could get
away with cheating during the game
either if one person moved out of time
we're looking at you sang woo
then everyone had to start over
today's game is
tug of war
the performers did not have it easy
playing the often physically demanding
games when filming the series since they
really were going through the struggle
depicted on screen
the sweat effort and even chained
handcuffs securing them to the rope were
real
there definitely couldn't be much
movement between takes since everyone
was literally tied up together with a
scene like this there isn't really any
other way to do it than at one hundred
percent
maybe one of the most terrifying gasp
worthy moments in the show is seeing
guillen hanging between safety and the
end of the game for his whole team the
tension is real even though the platform
they were on was just a meter and a half
off the ground while swinging on a rope
is usually pretty fun this collective
rope swing down tells a very different
story and shows just how far the actors
and production went to bring the best
footage to the screen
my god i can't believe how cool that was
the moment after the most intense tug of
war we've ever seen is so still but we
can see just how exhausted each and
every actor is having just struggled and
fought for their lives literally this
shot is definitely needed as a moment of
pause after the insane game just played
resulting in so many lives lost this is
also a bit of a moment of reckoning this
was hard but whatever was coming next
would only be harder and they knew it
you know what i really thought we were
going to die out there
for the final face-off the sound stage
was a lot emptier with just gion and
sang wu competing but there were many
camera people often filming using
handheld video cameras to capture all
the frantic action not only that their
crew made it rain making the whole scene
just as dramatic as the gruesome fight
we see in the final cut as filming went
on the two actors only got more
disheveled with rain soaking through and
blood effects added throughout the
battle in order to get all the footage
they needed the actors had to be on
point at every moment
i won't let you leave here with that
money
the honeycomb scenes looked pretty
similar on set as they did in the show
with the exception of the childlike
drawn wallpaper the rest of the set was
filled with giant playground equipment
and the smell of freshly made dalgona
the korean honeycomb suite luckily the
actors didn't have to listen to the
actual loud noise each time a bullet was
fired as someone on set was in charge of
giving a shout to indicate the moment
instead so the performers had a solid
unified cue to react to
behind the scenes we get a glimpse of
just how hands-on the director was when
it came time to shoot
surprisingly the cavernous cool space
where we see the confrontation between
the police officer and a team member of
the squid game is real the opening on
the top of the cave and the murky pool
made the ideal setting no doubt the
actors felt totally immersed in the
story shooting these scenes were pretty
simple all they needed were a couple of
cameras the right costumes and the
actors chilling performances
do you want to die
the glimpses we get of the players lives
before the game offers such a colorful
backstory especially when we see them
with their families each of these scenes
were shot quite intimately and simply
focusing on the narrative and what these
relationships meant to the player which
translated to the screen beautifully
it's also one of the only times we get
to see a typical everyday aesthetic
making the stark contrast between the
real world and the squid game world even
more apparent
so which color do you want to play as
how could we forget the original squid
game filming this scene may have been
one of the simplest setups using an
existing playground space it only adds
to the realism of the show and offers a
great reminder of where the players
started as innocent children playing
games for fun instead of their lives
at that moment
i felt as if i owned the entire world
hanging out in the dorms between games
certainly wasn't any less stressful than
the games themselves
the bare bones set with the cool
industrial edge does the trick and the
feeling of the daunting space comes
through the screen what we saw in the
show was almost exactly what was
happening on set with all the added
cameras and crew people of course
we can't fall asleep tonight okay who
knows what someone else may try
many moments in the marbles game bring
intense connection and emotion the way
they shot these scenes was a pretty
stark difference from so many of the
large and intense games the fact that
the actors were in a small space
together with just a few crew members
around really helps the intimacy come
through and offers us the chance to get
up close and personal with these
characters and the short but meaningful
relationship they have playing marbles
we'll go around this town and take all
the marbles
one of the reasons the marbles game is
so effective is because of just how well
the setting transports us to the alleys
of a small village
it makes sense that this is the set the
team spent the most time building every
detail down to the stunning backdrops
moves us
it's no surprise they got the
performances they did the authenticity
of this world is remarkable
my wife and i have this one here
the cast of squid game had to commit 100
to intense requirements including
gaining weight enduring extreme
conditions and total confidentiality
the amount of physical stamina the
actors in squid games show is pretty
incredible and what makes it more
impressive is the fact that it's all
real the actors in the show had to stay
extremely fit so when they weren't
working hard on set they had to be
working out at the gym to make sure
they'd be able to achieve what was
needed everything from being able to
jump far enough during glass stepping
stones pulling during tug of war or
hanging onto the rope as it fell off the
edge battling other players viciously
all of this required a ton of strength
and agility so everyone had to make sure
they were in top form and able to
perform the impressive feats multiple
times on demand
filming for squid game didn't exactly
happen from 9 to 5 every day depending
on the needs of the scene the actors
sometimes had extremely early morning
calls or they began late and worked all
through the night many hours were spent
on set and each one was precious making
these long days very intense and
exhausting for the actors not to mention
the crew who arrived first and were the
last to leave
with such crazy hours we would expect
plenty of nice long breaks for the cast
when they were on set to rest and
recover while they did have a netflix
budget time is money and any breaks
taken while filming had to be short to
make sure they didn't fall behind
schedule so many of the scenes required
a huge setup and cleanup afterwards so
they had to be very diligent about
timing and getting the takes right
efficiently
if any of the actors received an
individual interview request it was a
no-go unless first cleared by the
production team with such a major show
and all the netflix hype the performers
of squid game have rocketed to worldwide
stardom and loads of fans want to hear
more from them the producing team for
the k drama was on top of everything
though marketing the show taking care of
their artists and making sure everything
went according to plan it might seem
intense but running a show this big
takes a lot of organization and work
it's evident the squid game crew is
pretty incredible at what they do
while everyone in the cast had to work
out and stay in shape in order to
perform each day the actor who played
doksu had to start work earlier since he
also needed to gain
nearly 40 pounds as well it was really
important in the show for his character
to have a large physical build and this
was definitely one rule not broken this
intense physical transformation did come
at a cost though the combination left
the actor exhausted really feeling the
effects on set in his body but he
continued to push his limits every day
his body couldn't quite take it anymore
when filming took a war
between takes the always tough duksu was
throwing up from physical exertion and
discomfort even after filming wrapped
the actor continued to experience
negative effects
when these actors were cast contracts
had to be signed and those included
strict confidentiality agreements the
actors had to be tight-lipped and
discreet about the show making sure not
to give away any details even if they
seemed insignificant as we know from
watching squid game pretty well nothing
we see doesn't have some other meaning
while they were working on such an
exciting show and may have wanted to
share stories from the set the only
people the cast could talk about their
work to were other cast members the
secrets of the set even had to be kept
from their closest friends and family
after a long hard day's work plenty of
people want to have a drink and let off
some steam but not everyone is in the
cast of squid game the saviok actress is
pretty used to the model lifestyle late
nights big parties great drinks
and she loves it
the actress was often eager to go out
after work but her invites to fellow
cast mates typically were declined since
the actors had physically mentally and
emotionally intense work to do every day
they couldn't afford to have anything
negatively affect them anupam
may be a breakout netflix star but he's
also still an acting student the
performer was filming full time for
squid game while also devoting
significant time to his thesis his show
schedule filming was hectic enough
itself so adding all the extra work that
comes with working on a thesis during
supposed down time definitely makes for
a tough experience i had to finish my
thesis also but
still it's going on let's see how it
turned out tripathy had to make sure
neither would conflict with the other so
he could stay focused all the while
giving 100 to both he was definitely
worn pretty thin by the end but
fortunately he loves what he does and
has a great attitude about being a
student of acting forever just another
reason to be impressed by this amazing
performer
is it just us or are the rules of the
actual squid game pretty confusing
whether or not the actors had actually
played or known these games during their
childhoods everyone got pretty familiar
with the activities by the end of
filming these performers couldn't just
act out what they were doing and have
stunt doubles come in and take over when
the time came for the intense games
every actor had to really understand how
to play they weren't messing around even
the dalgonia honeycomb candies were real
definitely a tricky one especially for
those unfortunate players in the
umbrella category
there were plenty of scenes when the
actors real-life fear was perfect for
the cameras like the overwhelming energy
in the tug of war or the trembling hands
during the honeycomb game however there
were moments that actors had to be up
close and personal with danger whether
it was facing a weapon or trying not to
move while their hearts were racing
during red light green light it was
vital for the actors not to flinch no
matter how exhausted or nervous they may
have been in overwhelming scenes in
order to capture what needed to happen
the vip room holds a lot of strange
vibes from all of its guests being
masked to the real human animal hybrid
living statues these aren't shockingly
realistic props the actors who were cast
as these roles were required to be
covered in full body paint and behave
still as statues their eerie presence is
incredible and they really make an
impact even if they are just in the
background
just tell us about the next game the say
bjork actress isn't from the same region
as her character is in the show so she
had to make sure to hide her own accent
as it's different from how she needed to
sound before she started filming the
actress had to work diligently with an
accent coach to help her sound authentic
and throughout filming it was something
she always had to keep an ear out for
since the wrong accent would be
noticeable to anyone who knew the region
and it would have broken the illusion of
realism we get throughout the show
who knew that a game this deadly could
look this good quite a bit went into the
fashion behind squid game from an actor
refusing to dye his hair to its symbolic
costumes
who plays kong sebiok in the show is
known for being one of the top fashion
models in her career and her stunning
looks have won her awards
obviously it would not be that realistic
if chung would still look glamorous
while competing in the titular game so
the actress had to go through quite the
lengthy makeup process on set this
required the makeup team to make sure
that chong's hair would look messy but
not overly messy while also having to
apply fake scratches and bruises to her
face
kyoun's red hair in his final scenes of
season one was actually something that
was in the script and not a choice that
was made later on fans weren't the only
ones taken aback by the choice as kyun
himself lee yong-jae was also surprised
by the choice as well i talked to the
director and asked why i should dye my
hair red because it's a color that
ordinary men at kiun's age don't do i
think it was a will to show actions that
go beyond the limits that people think
kihun would never do
in the end youngjae didn't die his
actual hair red but instead simply wore
a wig if i dye my hair red i can't do
anything else director huangdong hyuk
thought long and hard about what kihoon
would dye his hair in the season finale
i imagined being him and thought to
myself what is the color that you would
never choose to dye your hair then i
came to the conclusion that kihoon would
never dye his hair red it would be the
craziest thing for him to do so i chose
the color and i thought it really showed
his inner anger
a lot of eyes were focused on the odd
looking masks worn by the soldiers that
are all black aside from the white
shapes in the middle which are either
circles squares or triangles the shapes
on the masks were actually inspired by
how ant colonies work as ants follow a
structure where each is given a specific
duty and role but from a distance it's
hard to tell the ants apart each shape
on the mask has a different meaning for
a different obligation for each soldier
the circles represent workers the
triangles represent soldiers and lastly
the squares represent managers
of this
one of the most notable and noticeable
wardrobe pieces in all of squid game is
the teal tracksuits the players wear
complete with their number printed onto
their chest as well as white strap-on
knock-off van's tennis shoes underneath
the costume the characters wear white
t-shirts with their numbers once again
printed across their chest in the same
teal color the color scheme was a
deliberate choice by the series director
huangdong hyuk who wanted the cast to
have costumes that would contrast from
the pastel colored sets and the red
overalls worn by the staff such pretty
colors for such a grim and mature series
one of the concepts that factored into
the choice of the green jumpsuits was
the fact that the creative team wanted
the costumes to create more tension
something more laid-back and casual
would feel out of place for a game of
survival while military-inspired battle
armor would feel like something a bit
more appropriate even the jackets and
suits worn in similar franchises
centering around deadly games such as
the hunger games and battle royale may
have seemed like a more faithful fit the
combination between the more laid-back
style along with the high stakes of the
deadly games proved to be the winning
strategy helping create the show's
off-beat and intense energy
two of the most prominent colors
throughout squid game are of course
green and hot pink which is obvious just
from looking at the costumes director
huangdong hyuk chose the color green for
the jumpsuits as it reminded him of what
korean high school students wore when he
was young the reasoning behind these two
sides not dressed individually but
instead as a group was because donghyuk
wanted to convey the themes of
conformity the choice of the pink
outfits worn by the staff wasn't just
made because of how it'd look visually
but there is also a metaphorical reason
as well
the soldiers are clad in hot pink as the
color is on the opposite side of the
color wheel from the color of the teal
jumpsuits another reason hot pink was
used on their clothes was because
director huang dong-hyuk felt the color
pink would elicit fear in a sense of
irony as pink is often a color used to
convey sensitivity or sweetness this is
also why the walls of the hallway
between the dorms and the game area are
hot pink as well while western audiences
may not be as familiar with south korean
idols hoyan is a close friend of jenny
from the k-pop group black pink oyen was
not the only one inspired by her friend
as the black and pink color scheme of
the workers and the coffins also was a
fun little callback to the group that
was director of huangdong hyuk's idea
that's a pretty light-hearted reference
for such a dark show
the use of numbers on the jumpsuits was
an intricate choice made by huang
dong-hyuk the reasoning behind the
clothing being marked with numbers over
names was because the director wanted it
to signify just how the oppressive force
in the series is robbing the contestants
of their identity each jumpsuit made for
the series had a three-digit number
stitched to the chest ranging from 1 to
456
the same number was also printed on all
the t-shirts that the actors and
actresses would wear under their
jumpsuits
there has been plenty of internet
speculation on why the guards are
wearing red unlike the green jumpsuits
worn by the contestants and the hot pink
jumpsuits worn by the staff red is often
used to convey themes of battle and rage
which is one of the reasons why it was
selected red was also used to symbolize
the color of blood and with all the
fresh gunshot wounds that are present
throughout the series it is easy to see
why it was chosen your shift's over
the hot pink costumes for the faceless
masked men almost had a completely
different look according to director
huangdong hyuk initially donghyuk wanted
to give the characters uniforms that
resembled that of a boy scouts at first
i wanted a boy scout like outfit but it
showed the men's figures too well
[Music]
before their final design the black
masks went through several design phases
before settling on one that would be
inspired by ant colonies art director
che kyung sun revealed that they almost
went even weirder with the mask designs
and that making the masks animal themed
was another idea that was thrown around
kyungsun was inspired by fencing masks
as well as the traditional korean masks
known as haihotel she expressed that she
needed to find a way so the masks could
portray the characters exerting their
class but at the same time the masks
needed to be comfortable to wear and
easy to see through director huangdong
hook also requested that the black masks
be foldable much like that of the mouth
of an ant while animal masks may have
proven to be creepy there's no denying
that the ominous final product added
greatly to the unnerving nature of the
show those shapes will never look the
same way again
chong's makeup process has even gone on
to kick start a trend on tiktok where
many users have attempted to create the
makeup process for her character from
fake freckles curtain bangs a wolf cut
eyeshadow for eye bags defining eyebrows
and perfecting a flushed chapped lip
some of the results have ended up
looking strikingly similar to the actual
show maybe these tick tock artists will
be hired on to the makeup team if
netflix ever wanted to move forward with
a season two and while donghyuk may be
denying a second season right now it's
hard to ignore just how big of a success
it is how about you use your body to pay
know what
many performers real-life nerves turned
out to be very handy on the set of squid
game the only thing worse than watching
the intensely terrifying games played in
squid game would be doing them but that
was the reality for the whole cast who
were often challenged mentally and
physically with such difficult material
if you haven't binged the entire wild
series yet consider this year's spoiler
alert one of the children's games with
the twist played during squid game was
tug of war a game that is hardly ever
actually played and when it is usually
by children while the simple battle
doesn't feel too high stakes the
consequences of losing this game were
fatal it was also very dangerous to film
on set the amped up game of tug of war
was filmed while the actors were
standing on raised platforms so when one
team lost those people literally fell
down and had a terrifying experience
not only was it scary there were
definite risks of injury as they flew
off these platforms only further
intensifying the energy of the scene
my god i can't believe how cool that was
the creative team didn't want the actors
to fake it so everyone dove right in
while it was nerve-wracking the actors
had to commit to their performances
fully meaning all that strength exerted
and sweat we see is 100 percent real
before you die
on top of the danger elements what we
don't really consider is just how much
more intense the game is when full-grown
adults are playing luckily no one was
badly injured while filming you know
what i really thought we were going to
die out there
filming the glass stones game was
actually terrifying for many of the
actors facing the nerve-wracking game
while they weren't set up at the
death-defying height we see in the show
they were still about a meter and a half
up and that height alone was enough to
make nerves settle in the performers
were walking on pieces of plexiglass
that could break from underneath them at
any time
before the time came to actually shoot
the high intensity scene the actors
nerves were very present and they didn't
go away while filming either the game
never got any easier and while the
actor's hesitance and worry about
filming the sequence could have ruined
the takes it actually wound up being the
best thing we're in hell here there's no
rules in hell
the intensity of the frightening tasks
was amplified and made these scenes even
stronger the camera doesn't lie and was
able to capture just how stiff and rigid
the actors bodies were adding an extra
layer of freaky realism to the scene as
we saw them genuinely struggle to face
their fears of course filming on a
precarious set was just one hurdle
considering how intense the content was
and how high the stakes were
psychologically the actors definitely
struggled with the whole process and
with very good reason luckily it all
worked out very well for the show we
absolutely feel the terror of these
performers through the screen
oh it's getting exciting
typically when a production has stunts
and scenes as risky and dangerous as
what we see being done in the squid game
there are a whole crew of stunt doubles
specially trained to face the danger
safely and take over when the cameras
were rolling practically it makes sense
the stunt doubles need to be there to
take center stage and perform so the
actors don't risk injury but in the case
of squid game the spotlight was on the
performers
they may have been children's games but
these were some very adult versions
falling from heights exerting great
physical strength and terrifyingly
stepping on glass stones that could
break at any second was just another day
at work for the squid game crew this is
a major testament to just how dedicated
the cast and crew were to telling and
depicting the story of the series as
honestly as possible it's our lives
we're betting on right now
and we gotta win the very first of the
squid game installments was the simple
childhood red light green light game and
while it seems innocent enough it was
far from fun having to freeze was really
tough since the performers had to
pretend to be so terrified and worried
they could lose their life because of
the slightest movement at the wrong time
the environment really just made
everything even more uncomfortable since
there was such a large crowd dressed
almost identically really inspiring a
bit of a freak mob mentality we're like
a bunch of soldiers at training camp huh
there were moments filming for the
actors that felt just a bit too much
like real life and mentally the
performers could struggle with negative
and dark thoughts this team committed to
their craft and put so much of
themselves into it that by the end of
the day many could feel depleted and
overwhelmed by the experience and some
were just frustrated with their
characters choices and what they needed
the 218 actor even expressed extreme
anxiety when preparing to do his role
but thanks to their awesome director he
felt confident in their work and the
script and managed to perform
the squid game premises is wild and part
of what makes it so unsettling is the
freaky and intricate sets the colors
shapes and styles give off unnerving and
creepy vibes so it's no surprise that
the first day the actors saw where they
would be filming their cameras were
immediately whipped out to capture
photos of it all
while it may have seemed like a dream
more often than not the circumstances
felt like a total nightmare being on
some of the bright and happy sets that
induced a sort of feeling of fantasy
could feel like being in a different
world
but in conjunction with the disturbing
content being depicted the scenes became
much worse to endure the sheer range of
realistic sets is impressive the actors
appeared to be outdoors or in the
alleyways from when they were children
but it was all just an illusion adding
even more to the creep factor
it's no surprise some of the actors felt
mentally challenged and drained while
working in these unnerving environments
you saved me
this show wouldn't have worked in
bringing the gruesome and intense
content to the screen had it not been
for the director's vision to make sure
he could get the strongest reactions
from the actors the leader of the team
made the performers feel safe enough to
trust him on the journey this allowed
the intense approach they took by having
all the actors do the games for real
without the fatal consequences of course
by placing the actors in overwhelming
scenarios where their adrenaline would
naturally run high the team managed to
capture some very honest and intense
performances
why did you do that to us
while the actors knew they wouldn't get
any more money than just their paychecks
for their performances that didn't stop
one actor from thinking about what he
might do if he had the opportunity to
play this unbelievable game in real life
the actor who plays the cop in the show
might not go toe-to-toe with the other
actors on set but he's the most likely
of them all to do the game in real life
if given the chance
the actor has confirmed that he'd
consider the daring task with a cash
reward that obviously can convince
people to risk everything
from leading roles major brand
sponsorships millions of dollars and
global recognition the actors of squid
game have encountered opportunities they
never could have imagined this might be
a little bit bigger than my usual
project she may have been a successful
model before but now hoyon is a global
star she can earn around 43 000. per
sponsored instagram post and she's
working in partnership with huge brands
like adidas and louis vuitton definitely
worth the investment for these companies
since she's the most popular south
korean actress on instagram
while the wealth and popularity have had
a huge effect on the say buck actress
she felt pretty changed as a person as
well hoiyon grew very close to her
character and had a hard time letting
her go sometimes feeling like sebiak's
voice comes through in her always
teaching and changing her for the better
chung-jae didn't have instagram before
squid game so he opened up an account
and made his first post just a couple
weeks after the show premiered and
quickly gained over 4 million followers
the actor has been lurking on social
media now that memes photos and fan
theories for squid game have been taking
over and he's even found a light in the
parody videos
the actor feels in terms of his career
the show's success hasn't done a lot for
him but the day-to-day has been very
different because suddenly he's being
recognized whenever he's out the gion
actor is already busy work on another
project and while he hasn't heard from
any north american companies about doing
a project with them he's very open to
the idea and would jump at the chance to
travel and film overseas
the police officer on a mission has had
quite the rise in popularity and his
cover of men's health korea definitely
helped it's no surprise his follower
count jumped from around 300 000 to
about 9 million his life didn't just
change financially and professionally
though he actually overcame a phobia of
water after the show because of all the
lessons and work he had to do for
underwater filming in the series it was
a big step but one that's been very
worth it for the actor
[Music]
heisu is already busy and booked on
other projects including the film ghost
and two netflix shows suranam and a
korean adaptation of another popular
series money heist with a net worth of
around three to four million this actor
is definitely earning his success
the biggest change since the show though
would be his new role as a father to a
baby nicknamed baby squid who happened
to be born the day the show premiered
talk about a life turning upside down
the creator and director of squid game
has been blown away by just how
successful the program has been and
shocked by the fact that he could find
this kind of success it's of course been
a pretty emotional time considering how
quickly squid game rose to success
especially since he wrote the series
over a decade ago there has been a ton
of demand for a second season but huang
had never actually planned on another
one however there were some cliffhangers
at the end of the first season and fans
have offered all sorts of amazing ideas
and theories that have really inspired
the director's thinking while the
pressure is definitely high he's opened
and excited to potentially bring squid
game back for another season
i'll steal the ideas from the fans
player one the mastermind behind squid
game was in control on the show but in
real life he's been extremely
overwhelmed with all the buzz around
himself and the series while he's been
acting for many years he's never gotten
so many inquiries and offers so his
daughter had to start helping him run
his career since he never had a manager
who'd normally take care of these
matters the actor has already been
offered starring roles in tv commercials
and has had to turn some down we can
only imagine how many people would
recognize him out in public if he did
commercials as well the actor only
recently came to terms with just how
tough it can be to be famous
the actor originally from india has
become extremely popular and is getting
way more recognition than he ever
thought he would people are taking
selfies they want to take autographs and
with the exposure has come the hope that
maybe he could perform in india and in
his own language the journey he had to
get to this point in his career is
exceptional
he moved to korea because he had a
scholarship to study and now he's worth
around half a million dollars we have a
feeling his dream to perform in front of
his hometown audience is pretty probable
at this point well these days there's
so many calls
while the actor is now a self-proclaimed
millionaire after reaching 1 million
followers on instagram
his health did suffer in the process of
making the show because of how quickly
he bulked up and gained weight resulting
in him often being sick and really
struggling during the strenuous days on
set he is still dealing with the
ramifications of the intense body
transformation leaving him wary to take
on any jobs that require him to gain
that much weight so quickly it hasn't
all been bad though the actor can make
around 1 000 per sponsored instagram
post
the front man actor in the series is
actually one of the few south korean
actors who's established a reputation in
hollywood in the gi joe films and
terminator genesis
while in the states he dealt with some
racism on sets but with the success of
squid game he hasn't given up on
hollywood yet and he's still wanting to
make films in the u.s his growing
popularity and central role as the
mysterious front man has given way to
rumors that a second season could focus
on his story our fingers are crossed
dream come true
so
that's great thing the vips and squid
game were talked about but not
necessarily for the right reasons since
there has been a lot of criticism about
their performances in the hit show the
actor who played vip number four isn't
too bothered by the negative reactions
since he's still been receiving a ton of
recognition the actor also gets fan mail
autograph requests and one admirer even
went so far as to tattoo both his real
name and the character's name on her arm
definitely not much to complain about in
his own words
i'm in the most popular film
in the history of television as for vip
number two all the flack wasn't so great
and he was pretty upset by the comments
mostly i just try to take what i can
from the negativity or the you know the
criticisms vip number one wasn't a fan
of being distant reviews but he's also
aware of the stereotypes that exist in
the entertainment industry for
westerners in south korea vip1 has
mainly been advocating for actors like
himself making sure to explain that they
do still have to go through a rigorous
audition process to book a role instead
of just being picked up off the streets
the actor who played the slick recruiter
in the series was actually one of the
biggest names in the show he rose to
international fame when he did the film
trained to busan his performance in the
netflix series earned him even more fans
and many of the squid game followers are
hoping that he'll have a leading role if
there's a second season
perhaps the strangest change he's
encountered since the show took off has
been the fact that now loads of people
want to be slapped by him and aren't shy
in letting the actor know
performing since she was a teenager yumi
is a seasoned actor now but nothing
prepared her for the rapid rise to fame
while she had an impressive 40 000
followers on instagram before the show
came out she very quickly gained about 6
million more fans professionally the
ball is kept rolling and she's already
filming other projects including a
netflix film called all of us are dead
as for her personal life squid game
brought the actress one of her closest
friends she and hoiyon talk to each
other every day having developed an
incredible real-life friendship
the cast of squid game features a mix of
incredible actors who got straight
offers and unknown performers who blew
the team away in their auditions
all of which made a major impression on
fans
the model turned actress had only been
with her acting agency for one month
before she'd gotten the opportunity to
submit a self-tape for the netflix hit
it was the very first audition she'd
done by tape and had a ton of nerves
going in but in the midst of her frantic
prep she dove into the script and turned
out what happened to be a tape good
enough to earn her an in-person audition
in korea what makes this even more
impressive is the fact that she was busy
doing fashion week in new york when the
request came to her but once the
callback came she hopped on a flight to
korea nerves ran high for the actress
and the experience of being in the room
with the director was intense she even
had to stop drinking coffee because of
the anxiety all this caused
while by this point she was already
playing sebiak and doing a lot of
research on north korean defectors to
prep for her role the actress wasn't so
confident so she requested dinner with
director huang to make sure they were on
the same page and she was meeting
expectations
of course she was blowing it out of the
water and huang was able to confirm with
her that she was a great actress and the
perfect one to play the complex and
strong character
if it seems like the guillen actor
suited his role perfectly it's probably
because the part was actually written
specifically for him
director huang had hoped the incredible
actor would accept the offer to play the
role and luckily for everyone he said
yes the decision was pretty easy since
the actor had always wanted to work with
the director
the incredible story lines in the script
made the answer pretty easy as well when
it came to preparing for the role the
relationship between him and sang wu was
important so the actors actually spent a
lot of time together bonding and
drinking wine this sounds like pretty
great acting prep to us
while he wasn't the first choice to play
ali anubham tripathi definitely made an
impact with his portrayal on squid game
the actor originally from india actually
studied acting in south korea and in
january 2020 a korean casting agency
reached out to him and he sent in his
tape for squid game
once he'd had his in-person audition
with the director and showed off his
emotional acting the actor was booked he
went hard at work with research and
preparing to play a pakistani character
truthfully i asked my pakistani friends
and all to help me with the language in
fact it was his internal quest all the
way from the day they said yes his
enthusiasm and commitment no doubt made
him an excellent addition to the show
we're definitely glad he was part of
this cast even if ali didn't get what he
deserved in the series
easy in a sense like okay i got the role
hard because i have to prepare for the
role hajin was honored to be part of
squid game especially because of how
much he wanted it when he first went in
to audition having wanted to move
towards more serious work instead of the
usual rom-coms he'd been performing in
the actor was overwhelmed by the idea of
working on such an incredible korean
project with amazing talent attached he
made sure to give it his best in the
audition and luckily it left an
impression while he knew the police
officer was a smaller role the storyline
really intrigued him and he worked a lot
to make sure he explored the internal
struggle in his character and depicted
how much he tried to achieve justice
this wasn't the first time the duksu
actor and creator of squid game have
worked together the two collaborated on
the 2017 film the fortress director
huang had no trouble picturing this
incredible actor as the menacing doksu
since the actor often plays gang members
the creator did end up apologizing to
the actor for giving him yet another
tough credit we have a feeling the
performer was very much okay with this
one though the fact that the actor is
the opposite of his character in real
life is a testament to his acting skills
as well
especially considering he didn't start
his career until much later in life
the sang-woo actor actually didn't need
to audition director huang wrote the
role with the actor's voice in his head
as with gyan the casting process wasn't
so much an audition as a question an
easy one to answer since the actor had
the director and chung-jae on his list
of people he'd hoped to work with one
day he was pretty glad he wound up
spending so much time on that set since
he gained valuable insights about acting
itself and the industry from his co-star
as if the incredible team wasn't enough
to be excited about the seng-wu actor
knew straight away he wanted to see how
he could bring the complex character to
life it was definitely meant to be since
his child nicknamed baby squid was born
the day the show was released
we know him as player 276 but the
filipino actor christian lagahed
originally auditioned to play ali
unfortunately that audition didn't pan
out but something about his performance
must have captured the attention of the
casting team since after not hearing
anything for a while the actor got a
call with a straight offer to be part of
the show it might have been a minor role
but it was a major win for the actor as
he's been living in south korea since
2015 and felt a lot of pride getting to
represent minorities on screen
he also found a new friend in the person
who did end up playing ali the two
actors were often goofing around and
filming each other on set say hi to my
blog brother
while mignole might seem like a smaller
role the character was actually
extremely important for the director and
he wanted to make sure he had the
perfect actor to do it justice so he
jumped at asking this special actress to
portray the part of player 2-1-2 the
show hadn't even been totally green lit
but the director reached out to check on
the actress's schedule and when the show
was ready to go the contracts were
signed the 212 actress had an emotional
time reading the script and while she
had mixed feelings it got her excited
and she was eventually thankful for the
whole dreamlike experience
actor carlo aquino really regretted not
being able to be part of squid game
especially after he'd been specifically
requested by the director to audition
the actor had given such a memorable
performance in a past project squid
games director requested he do a tape
for the part of ali
one which he really did suit and
actually booked the job for
unfortunately because travel
restrictions were in place aquino wound
up not being able to film the show lucky
for us anupam tripathi jumped into the
role but still a tough break for aquino
while he didn't end up in the series he
still managed to get himself a green
tracksuit
since there aren't many foreign actors
in korea the pandemic travel
restrictions really proved to be a
challenge when the team was seeking out
performers to play the vips in the show
vip number four the one we hear speak
the most was found and brought over from
thailand to shoot while the rest were
really selected because they didn't have
that many options
these extras auditioned and eventually
booked the jobs playing the despicable
vips
the creator of squid game definitely
lucked out in terms of the cast who
signed on to be part of this special
project which character would you want
to play